[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il vous parlait très souvent tous les
soirs tous les soirs il vous a parlé
direct non non au début c'est personne
se parle ouais et après quoi vousz
demander pourquoi il était là même pas
tu me l'as dit direct ouais et alors
justement euh il il vous a dit quoi par
ça son affaire je connaissais pas du
tout ah vous connaissiez pas du tout la
f arrivé du Portugal pas du tout ah
ouais ouais Interpol m'a ramené en
France d' cord et je suivais pas les
infos
médias on a fait connaissance par
rapport aux autres personnes que je
connaissais de là il a plus de confiance
à s'ouvrir est-ce que
euh votre but c'était de le faire avouer
ou pas du tout vous voulez discuter avec
vrai au début non c pour qu'il me laisse
tranquille je l'écouté 5 minutes après
j'allais me poser ouais quoi il parlait
beaucoup toute la nuit à toute la nuit
ah ouais quand même
euh vous avez encore c'est nouvel ou pas
du tout non pas du tout il il vous en TR
avec la France ouais ça vous savez même
pas si'il vous en a voulu d'avoir parl
après il s'en fout en plus pas du tout
c'est sûr que oui oh non il est il est
possible alors il faut il faut dire
quand même que que Marco a été confronté
à Cédric jubilire dans le dans le
cabinet des juges d'instruction c'était
je crois au mois de mai 2022 là pendant
plusieurs heures vous avez été bah voilà
mis mis euh mis mis en face l'un l'un de
l'autre et puis euh les juges ont essayé
de de et bien de de demander comment
c'est ce que Cédric jubilard pensait de
de vos révélations puisque vous aviez
expliqué notamment alors il va nous
expliqu alors justement parce que vous
aviez révélé que Cédric jubilard vous
avez avoué avoir tué sa femme vous a
raconté quoi exactement débarrassé
débarrassé alors il vous a dit quoi il
vous a dit je me suis débarrassé de ma
femme non il m'a dit je suis dans ma
chambre j'ai plus de batterie dans mon
téléphone je suis parti au salon prend
mon chargeur pendant ce moment-là j'ai
vu que l'autre connard lui envoyé des
messages donc j'ai pété les PL je m suis
débarrassé c'est ça donc c'était son
amant forcément donc voilà donc
et vous avez essayé d'en savoir plus sur
son récit
oui vite fait peu à peu peu à peu parce
qu'il s livrait que par par phase ouais
que par phase après quand il commence à
fumer c'était ah il fumait des ben ouais
ouais et donc là il balançait tout il
peut réfléchisser plus
euh vous avez cru tout de suite à son
récit ou pense qu'il était mytho même
pas je m'inttéressa au début
ouais je m'intéress je l' laissé parler
1 heure 2h oui oui oui après je vais me
poser
et parce que est-ce que pour vous euh
tout ce qui enfin il pensz qu'il a s'est
vraiment débarrassé de sa femme oui
comme il dit oui oui vousz vous avez pas
de doute non c'est pas un mytho il a pas
voulu faire non il est pas mytho il est
très intelligent ah ouais ouais vraiment
non très intelligent j'en ai croisé
beaucoup Ahou des abrutis des
intelligents des moyens ouais lui ça va
il est dans la norme dans la norme ou il
est un peu au-dessus non dans la norme
des intelligents il dans une lettre
adressée à à Séverine sa nouvelle
compagne il écrit dans un message codé
que vous êtes une personne capable de
les aider pourquoi il a dit ça le passé
he mon passé ah c'est ça ouais pour quoi
les aider dans quoi vous les aider dans
quoi en tout
c'està-dire je peux les aider à sortir
la galère vous l'aidiez au placard ou
pas jeenvoie fumer c'est pas aidé ouais
vous l'aidiez pas du tout non non je
l'écoutis je parlais avec lui c'est tout
euh ou non ouais je je crois que pour
pour pour bien comprendre et là vous
m'arrêtez Marco parce qu'il y a que vous
qui pouvez savoirin mais ce que j'ai
compris de la dynamique de vos échanges
c'est que Cédric jubilard sait que vous
allez sortir de prison dans quelques
jours quelques semaines là là on est au
mois de septembre mois de septembre 2021
lui vient d'arriver en prison et il
découvre cet univers carcéral et et et
et vous êtes voisins de cellule vous ne
vous voyez jamais d'ailleurs parce que
l'un et l'autre sont à l'isolement donc
vous communiquez comme ça à travers les
les barreaux mais vous ne vous voyez
jamais physiquement et et là il compte
aussi sur vous pour faire passer un
message et pour faire le lien avec
Séverine qui qui est sa sa sa petite
amie à l'époque hein puisque désormais
ce ce n'est plus le cas mais euh il
compte sur vous pour faire passer un
message qui qui contournerait un peu le
la la justice donc voilà une fois qu'on
a dit ça bon c'était quoi comment vous
êtes rentré en contact avec sine il m'a
donné il m'a écrit son adresse son
numéro de téléphone tout ouais il les a
écrit de ses mains et je sorti je l'ai
appelé on marqu rendez-vous oui vous
avez révélé qu'elle vous avait donné les
les coordonnées GPS du lieu où Cédric
aurait enterré le corps de Delphine les
photos des amants les lieux m m'a appelé
en direct du local mais mais Séverine
elle démon cette information elle est
enregistrée moi j'ai transmis mis tous
les enregistrements au tribunal ouais
non mais disons que Séverine là encore
vous m'arrêtez elle a elle a un moment
elle a elle a fait un rapprochement
d'idée vous Marco vous lui avez dit que
Cédric vous avez parlé d'un endroit qui
avait brûlé et elle par association
d'idées pense à une ferme qui a brûlé
sur la commune de canlémin à un moment
où c'est vrai cédric est encore en en
liberté là au printemps 2021 et par donc
cette association d'idées elle en vient
à vous dire bah peut-être que c'est là
mais elle-même Séverine en réalité n'en
sait rien parce qu'elle était placée
quand même en garde à vue c'est ça ça
était quand même une affaire dans
l'affaire là on est en fin d'année 2021
elle est placée en garde à vue Séverine
et elle elle est mise en cause pour
celle de cadavre he on parle quand même
de ça et finalement elle sort de sa
garde à vue totalement libre parce que
les enquêteurs de la SR de la section de
recherche de Toulouse ont compris qu'en
réalité il ne savaiit rien mais mais il
y a eu cette idée peut-être que elle
allait mettre enfin les enquêteurs sur
une bonne piste mais cet endroit a été
fouillé pendant des semaines et et ils
n'ont rien trouvé malheureusement Marco
il vous avez pas essayé de savoir vous
euh quand vous étiez euh en vrai j'avais
pas trop moi je partais le 25 il est
arrivéugal ouais le 27 je me mariais je
partais plusutôt d'accord donc j'ai tiré
la corord jusquà où j'ai pu après ouais
vous avez pas pu savoir où était le
corps de
Delphine malheureusement Marco vous vous
avez raconté que Cédric jubilard en
prison il jouit un peu les caïdes il
voulait être la star de la prison et
cetera pasaï St un peu les non mais un
peu les les stars on est d'accord
là-dessus est-ce que il aurait pu
bidonner tout inventer pour vous faire
croire à vous qui étiez une personne
très connue dans la prison qu'il avait
des choses intéressantes à dire est-ce
que ça pourrait être complètement faux
vous fa insulter du matin au soir ah
ouais donc il va pas raconter quelque
chose qui à peine il ouvre la fenêtre
fait insulter sa
maman il se fais insulter tout le temps
matin midi et soir pourquoi pour
pourquoi zv la place des personnes vous
avez deux enfants qui ont plus perdu
leur mère et ils font dans une cellule
bien sû bravo oui tous les mecs comme ça
forcément placard il sont insultter donc
pour vous il vous a dit la vérité oui
parce qu'il me l'a écrit il m' envoyé
des messages il disait par phase et la
vérité on peut pas la tromper le
mensonge il revient à la vérité mais la
vérité il a pas de r point alors parce
que lui Cédric jubard il a démenti vous
avoir raconté tout ça en tout cas au
premier degré il dit que c'était non il
a pas démentié il dit dit dans le ton de
la rigolade c'est ça voilà exactement
ouais ça dépend les mesures de rigolade
des personnes qu' parle non
effectivement lui lui n'a pas n'a pas
contesté avoir tenu certains propos
après il dit il dit deux choses il dit
j'ai c'était sur le T de la rigolade et
après Marco peut-être a extrapolé
certaines choses euh c'est c'est sa
version à lui c'est comme ça qu'il se
défend et et et et après tout pourquoi
pas je veux dire on peut aussi imaginer
que dans un univers carcéral ou avec une
personnalité très narcissique comme
celle de C jubilard on s'invente une
chose pour pour exister aux yeux des
autres c'est possible c'est en tout cas
la ligne de défense qui est soutenu par
ses avocats Marco vous l'insultiez vous
au le début non j'insulte pas même pas
non pas du tout je parle aux autres
personnes mais vous disez quoi aux
autres détenus quand il l'insul disc
disz quoi dedans on est en prison on est
dans ou mais dehors on a une famille on
a des amis on a c'est dehors la vie
c'est pas dedans pour vous il y a aucun
doute non c'est
lui c'est vousz s de vous on dirait que
savez vous vous avez un truc un truc on
sait pas qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
vous a dit de plus déteeurs on a parlé
après quand on s'ouvre une quelquun on
reconnait on voit à peu près la personne
on discut un jour de jours 3 jours quand
on VI avec une personne 24 il vous a
raconté son histoire vous a dit que sa
femme avait tout les sousvêtements dans
le lieu de travail c'est quoi ça alors
dites-nous dans son lieu de travail ils
ont retrouvé des petites tenues qui
portaiit pas pour lui importe pour
l'autre connard plein de petits mots au
début il y a un peu de faux au début ça
ça modifie les paroles mais après quand
ça s'ouvre quand il est plus relâché
quand personne l'insulte quand il est
tranquille à la fenêtre quand tout le
monde s'entend bien on essaie de donc il
vous a il vous a raconté toute une
histoire il vous a dit que sa femme
avait un amant c'est ça çame le plus
coquu de France ah oui il vous a dit ça
j'étais l'homme le plus coccu de France
je suis l'homme le plus coccu de France
si vous a vous a raconé quoi comme autre
anecdote euh son fils il devait être
appelé comme mon le frère de mon
deuxième prénom plein de choses qui se
liit à moi il voulait m'offrir son chien
ah ouais j'en assz à la maison d'accord
ah ou oui Ren voulait dire quelque chose
non non mais c'est vrai que Cédric
jubilard est une
personnalité très étonnante très
déroutante et donc il est il est en
réalité il était en tout cas en
détension comme il
l'était en liberté pendant les 6 mois
dans pendant lesquels sa femme a disparu
et euh il se présentait à l'époque comme
le mec le plus connu du Tarne il
utilisait toujours et régulièrement des
superlatifs pour pour pour parler de
lui-même bon voilà après c'est sa
manière d'être ça veut pas dire pour
autant que c'est un coupable à cousp sû
euh mais il a une personnalité qui
déroute et qui risque si jamais il est
renvoyé devant une cours d'ASS qui est
quand même le cas le plus probable qui
risque de dérouter sérieusement les les
les membres du du jury Pascal Marco vous
avez beaucoup parlé avec Cédric jubilard
il a effectivement beaucoup baladé les
enquêteurs sa
personnalité vous la décrivriez comment
à quoi à qui ressemble-t-il à quoi
ressembleil comment il se comporte
pardon bascul sur B c'est c'est
vachement non mais c'est vachement
important sa personnalité c'est qui
Cédric jubilard quelquun qui a
énormément confiance en Lui ouais ok
même si j'ai tort j'ai raison ouais
c'est ça je vais le prouver ah ou vous
avez pas prouvé j'ai tort c'est ça donc
j'ai raison aujourd'hui vous êtes
aujourd'hui ça vaa j'ai ma femme ma
fille vous dites que pourquoi j'ai fait
toutes ces conneries ou pas demandez
parfois sur le moment même j'étais un
garçon très agité ouais mais aujourd'hui
est-ce que parce que on parle souvent
ici des des multirécidivistes euh est-ce
que vous Marco vous vous dites moi je
ferai plus UNE connerie maintenant si je
serais en France j'aurais pas pas dire
je pourrais pas dire ça pourquoi parce
que on va pas dire c'est les amis mais
le cercleamb l'ambiance l'environ le
donc donc non mais c'est très c'est
important ce que vous dites c'est fou ce
que vous dites ça veut dire que même
vous qui êtes euh vous étiez extrêmement
motivé à changer à tourner la page vous
avez une femme un enfant maintenant ou
des enfants vous avez combien d'enfants
j'ai une belle fille voà voilà et voilà
donc tout va bien B vous vous dites les
fréquentations et l'univers dans lequel
je vais me retrouver en sortant ça peut
me faire replonger donc c'est c'est fou
hein non mais c'est ça qui est grave et
donc c'est pour ça que vous êtes parti
ben ouais connais personne je REP à zéro
non mais c'est e c'est incroyable les
gars vraiment Marco je te le dis ne fait
plus eh oublie tout ça non mais vraiment
matin mi et soir voilà même le dimanche
d'accord on est bouleversé à chaque fois
qu'on entend le papa de Lola parler il a
des mots tellement justes tellement
forts il est il est il est tellement
vrai on se met tellement à sa place et
je suis vraiment je pense à lui tous les
jours depuis que j'ai vu son son
interview la semaine derère
cette nouvelle cette semaine il explique
aussi qu'il redoute le procès forcément
il a peur que la responsabilité de la
tueuse peut pour être mise en cause à
cause de son état psychologique instable
ça c'est on en avait on l'avait évoqué
ici très très dur ce témoignage alors
Michel Marie l'affire Lola donc ce sera
le procès en 2024 c'est ça je pense pas
que ça vienne en 2024 on n'est pas du
tout dans les délais ça sera encore plus
long ah oui probablement plus long le
délai raisonnable aujourd'hui entre le
moment où les faits sont commis et le
moment où l'auteur enfin le suspect
passe compara devant la Cour d'Assise
c'est minimum 3 ans d'abord il y a un an
et demi d'instruction minimum c'est
souvent 2 ans il faut dire que les juges
instruction en moyenne 170 ou 180
dossier en
simultané à gérer et le juge il est tout
seul je vous dis il faut don donner des
moyens à la justice parce que les juges
il peuvent pas tout faire non plus pas
traiter 180 dossiers par an il faut
peut-être ouvrir moins
d'information enfin c'est très compliqué
donc pour en venir au délai la moyenne
c'est 3 ans parce qu'après c'est pas une
fois que le juge a renvoyé le le dossier
à clôturé son dossier après il y a un
problème de
d'audiencement euh il y a des affaair il
y a à Paris je crois qu'il y a quatre
cours d'assise qui tournent à plein
régime et en permanence
euh et là encore les délais sont sont
longs un procès comme celui de de de
Dabia ça sera sera minimum une semaine
d'audience minimum ou Gill s'il y a un
procès ah oui parce que là c'est toute
la question hein elle a quand même
quitté la la prison de freine elle est
internée dans une unité spéciale pour
malade très difficile à ville juif et si
la première expertise a dit qu'il y
avait pas de troupe psychique ou
neuropsychique il y aura une
contreexpertise et vu son état
psychologique aujourd'hui elle se tapait
la tête contre les murs alors est-ce
qu'elle en fait trop est-ce qu'elle a
joué un peu ça c'est possible mais en
tout cas Cyril rien de garanti
aujourd'hui qu'elle sera jugée un jour
alors euh on vrait parler d'une autre
affaire parce qu'on va euh oui vouz dire
que oui je voulais dire que il faut pas
il faut pas crier avant d'avoir avant
d'avoir mal ou mais bon quand même là
dans ces cas-là il faut mieux non mais
il y a une première expertise qui dit
qu'elle n'est pas atteinte de de
troubles mentaux euh effectivement elle
a été mise dans une unité de pour malade
difficile mais plus pour la préserver
pour éviter qu'elle se suicide elle étit
placé à l'isolement et elle supportait
pas l'isolement et l'intérêt de tout le
monde c'est qu'elle arrive saine et
sauve devant la cour Daniel excusez-moi
mais je peux pas entendre ça quand je
vois ce que vit cet homme elle ne
supportait pas l'isolement mais
qu'est-ce qu'on en a à faire qu'elle
supporte pas l'isolement excusez-moi
qu'est-ce qu'on en a à faire de la
protéger on va payer pour la protéger
des années avec ce qu'on entend là moi
je excusez-moi je peux pas entendre mais
je vais vous répondre l'idée c'est
simplement qu'elle arrive au procès
vivante si elle se pend dans sa cellule
on aura tout perdu et et donc ça je
pense que c'est pas c'est pas forcément
euh euh faire offense à à à la famille
des victimes que de la placer dans une
unité médicale euh pour les gens
difficiles euh pour pas qu'elle se
suicide je sais ce que tu penses Ron moi
oui moi moi je moi vous savez tout ce
que je pense mais mais le problème c'est
que pourquoi 3 ans en fait vous l'avez
dit 180 cas mais il y a pas 180 cas
comme ça est-ce qu'on peut pas passer un
dossier en pensant au monsieur qu'on
vient de voir à l'antenne qui est obligé
d'attendre qui divorce ce pauvre
monsieurl est-ce qu'il y a 180 cas de de
de de personnes de petit de petit F
qu'on a mis dans un coffre dans une
malle qu'on a transporté à boisombe
qu'on a ramené à Paris peut-être qu'à un
moment donné on pourrait se dire ça ça
ça va passer un an on a tout on a toutes
les preuves on sait qui c'est on sait
qui a fait ça elle a avoué voilà un
moment donné ce que la justice peut pas
dire on n pas là pour parler de la
justice et faire leur dire comment on
doit faire mais est-ce qu'on peut pas
faire ça en plus rapide que 3 ans bien
sûr teniement on ou mais c'est tellement
logique vous avez entendu ce qu'il a dit
il a dit que ses journé faisait 48 he 24
he il attend ça pour essayer de tourner
une page vous rendez compte a la justice
mais il y a de l'humanité aussi marche
sur la tête quoi je sais bien c'est on
une question je répond
[Musique]
question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'angoisse voilà donc c'est vrai que
cette vidéo si vous nous rejoignez est
incroyable je v remercier Coraline
d'être avec nous merci d'être là merci
beaucoup vous allez nous raconé votre
histoire c'était le 25 mars dernier vous
êtes tranquille à la maison comme on
vient de de le voir dans la vidéo et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé benah j'étais
j'étais je viais de rentrer chez moi ça
faisait à peine 2 Hees merci c'est juste
pour votre micro est-ce qu'il est bien
broché le micro de de Coraline merci
c'est juste une tranche à monter c'est
rien de grave he merci c'est bon donc je
venais de rentrer chez moi depuis 2h à
peine et puis ça sonne donc à ma porte
je vais ouvrir et en fait le il y a un
jeune homme qui se fait passer pour un
voisin tu vous dit quoi il vous dit il
me dit bonjour excusez-moi excusez-moi
que suis avec ma copine j'aimerais
cuisiner il manque du papier d'aluminium
pour pour finir est-ce que vous pourriez
me vous ariez à me dépanner je dis bah
bien sûr et en fait par politesse je
laisse la porte entre ouverte en me
disant bah je vais pas lui fermer la
porte au nez et puis je pars dans la
cuisine et à ce moment-là je me mets à
trembler je je sens qu'il y a quelque
chose qui va pas et en sortant de la
cuisine en fait il m'attendait dans le
salon il m'a pris au coup directement il
a essayé de m'endormir oh là là en me
tapant voilà donc ça a été extrêmement
violent il vous a il vous a volé
beaucoup de choses en fait donc pendant
qu'il me tabassait au sol moi je suis
tombée évidemment euh il y en a un
deuxième qui est arrivé et là il me dit
ta montre elle est où ta montre et je
lui dis euh enfin je plus ce que je dis
en l'entend mais je sais plus mais il
voulait une montre en fait il voulait ma
montre donc je ne sais pas comment ils
ont réussi à à remonter jusqu'à enfin
jusqu'à jusque là mais ils savait ce
qu'il venait chercher donc bon c'est ça
a dû être la peur de votre vie forcément
ouais j'ai pensais que j'allais mourir
ouais c'est ça vous êtes dit un moment
ils vont me tuer comment vous savez
pensé à un moment ils vont me tuer mais
ils m'ont dit en fait ils m'ont menacé
que si je continuais de crier il allit
me tuer ah ouais oui oui ils me le
disent euh plusieurs fois donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu des ça se passe il y a
donc des menaces de mort euh ils
repartent ensuite vous savez combien de
temps ça a duré je dirais 2 minutes 2
minutes mais qui sonit plus long de
votre vie ouais ouais j'ai l'impression
que ça duré beaucoup plus longtemps mais
non c'était à peine 2 minutes bien sûr
ouais ça a été un truc de de fou ouais
c'est assez violent vous avez vous avez
porté plin bien entendu est-ce qu'ils
sont été appréhendés par la police
est-ce qu'ils ont été retrouvés ou pas
non pas du tout rien du tout ça fait un
an et demi que j'attends et absolument
un an et demi que vous attendez mais
vous vivez plus jamais comme avant alors
là vous non là je me retourne dans la
rue j'ai du mal à prendre des transports
j'ai même dans la rue même la journée ou
la nuit je suis tout en train de me
retourner voir si a quelqu'un derrière
moi toute seule non c'est ça je su à la
j'ai toutes les sécurités possibles mais
je dors mal TR qui va qui va vous suivre
à vie ouais je pense mais c'est sûr
ouais dès que ça sonne je tremble et
j'ouvre même plus maintenant je demande
et même si je j'attends quelqu'un si
c'est pas une copine je laisse rentrer
personne on pose les colis devant ma
porte bien sûr vous avez vous avez
déménagé ouais ouais normal vous pouvez
pas rester là-bas non je pouvais pas
ouais c'était impossible et c'est fou
parce que là vous avvez n'avez aucune
nouvelle vous avez forcément porté
plainte mais on vous a jamais dit qu'on
les a retrouvé ou un truc ça non et je
pense que on le retrouvera même pas ils
était jeune donc ça donait pas 20 ans 22
ans je dirais vraiment jeune peut-être
moins mais pas plus vous éta qu'agoulé
les avez vous a un qui n'était pas
qu'oul ah oui celui qui était venu il va
pas demander ah bah oui genre le gars il
arrive ài tu as du papier aluminium je
fais la cuisine avec ma femme là non non
mais alors du coup elle peut les décrire
c'est ça que non mais c'est une cadar le
gars il arrive qu' gouler excuse-moi je
suis en train de faire des poissons en
papillote
là idiote étonant c'est Coraline donc a
porté plainte l'enquête n'avance pas du
tout pour le moment elle a très peu de
contact avec le le commissariat qui a
pris la plainte alors que selon Coraline
elle aurait sans doute été suivie
espionnée et peut-être même ont-ils fait
des repérage avant en se faisant passer
pour de faux livreurs ou ce qu'on disait
hier est-ce que est-ce que je sais que
vous êtes vous êtes très présente sur
les réseaux est-ce que vous pensez que
ça a
joué pense que oui parce qu'en fait du
coup je suis créatce de contenu sur
insta et en fait j'ai posté une story 2
he avant en arrivant chez moi et je le
fais jamais sur mon P en disant je suis
enfin arrivé à la maison je des
rendez-vous médicaux et en fait 2 heures
après pile poil ça sonne donc ils savent
que je suis toute seule ils savent que
je suis chez moi alors que j'étais très
peu chez moi j'étais très souvent chez
mon
copain faites attention à ça c'est c'est
des infos incroyabl c'est des infos in
vous rendez compte en temps réel on sait
si vous êtes chez vous si vous êtes pas
chez vous c'est devenu les réseaux
sociaux c'est devenu maintenant les
cambrioleurs les mecs mal intion bien
sûr il y a des mecs qui sont dessus et
qui qui savent que ça tombe tout seul on
a vu hier la vidéo hein qui était avec
ses ses faux livreurs euh il y en a de
plus en plus un des homejing donc des
faux livreurs des livou ou des faux
voisins nous sommes en train de nous
frayer un chemin vers la trème guerre
mondiale on va voir cette vidéo d'Éon
musk un des hommes les plus puissants du
monde des plus riches du monde également
et il a déclaré je cite que nous nous
dirigeons tout droit vers une troème
guerre mondiale évidemment ce n'est pas
le seul à le penser alors doit-on avoir
peur on écoute ce qu' a dit el on en
parle juste après avec nos
spécialistes000
encore je pense qu'on se dirige
doucement vers une trème guerre mondiale
avec des décisions aussi bêtes les unes
que les
autres et les gens devrai vraiment
considérer que si leurs prédictions ne
se sont pas
réalisé les prochaines ne se réaliseront
peut-être pas non
plus alors elon mus qui dit çaé bien
entendu tout le monde tout le monde
était très très affolé par ça alors
Sergey gianov ancien espion du du KGB
est-ce qu'on risque une 3ème guerre
mondiale al d'abord la 3è guerre
mondiale s'est passé déjà la 3ème guerre
mondiale était la guerre froide elle a
commencé en 1946 et elle a terminé en
1991 ok merci fergay alors oui mais sauf
que là il faudra juste changer le
chiffre vers la 4è guerre mondiale
est-ce qu'on se dirige vers une 4è
guerre Mondi en fait c'est encore pire
que ça ah oui parce que on l' vit déjà
depuis 15 ans la 3 la 4è guerre mondiale
a commencé en le 8 décembre le 8 août
2008 tandis que le monde entier était à
Pékin pour l'ouverture des Jeux
olympiques d'été euh medvedef avec la
Russie a envahi la Géorgie pourquoi non
pas parce qu'il y avait les deux régions
qui étit frontalière la l' céti du Sud
et l'abcazie mais parce que la geéorgie
a voulu rentrer dans le temps et dans
l'Union européenne et donc la première
punition de Poutine après 2007 parce que
en 2007 il a prononcé un discours dont
euh les spécialistes euh les
spécialistes l'ont mararqué mais le
monde entier euh s'est dit oui c'est un
peu exagéré rien du tout et donc en fait
la Russie a commencé ça et après ils ont
regardé comment le monde allit allait
réagir et en fait le monde n'a pas réagi
euh Obama a dit euh en venant au pouvoir
à Medvedev qui qui était le remplaçant
de Poutine on va refaire nos relations
comme si euh l'ordinateur de Russie a
buggé et donc il faut le relancer et en
fait après il y a eu les accords les
accords de Sarkozi proposés par Sarkozi
et par Angela Merkel donc de faire la
paix et tout le monde s'est dit tout le
monde a fait le Doron tout le monde
s'est dit on va pas rentrer dans la 4e
guerre mondiale à cause d'un ce d'un
petit pays qui est la geurgie poutine
l'a compris 2014 Robelot annexion de la
Crimée après donbas et là pareil la même
chose personne n' réagi euh et là on est
arrivé au 24 février 2000 2022 là c'est
la guerre euh euh de la Russie euh
contre l'Ukraine vous vous souvenez
j'étais sur votre plateau le jour même
euh et euh je vous ai dit Poutine euh
veut faire peur euh au monde entier pour
que le monde ne bouge pas par rapport à
ça il est il est prêt à employer les
armes de euh nucléaire tactique tout le
monde a fait le tolet à C euh sur sur le
plateau tout le monde a dit il raconte
n'importe quoi sauf que 3 jours après
vous souvenez le dimanche 27 février
Poutine a convoqué le ministre de la
Défense chugou et le chef d'étatmajor
garassimov il a dit mettez les forces
nucléaires de Russie en alerte h et là
tout le monde a compris que c'est
c'était ça devenait grave depuis
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 24 octobre ça
fait 20 mois que cette guerre est menée
en Ukraine il ne se passe pas une
semaine que les Russes n'amène pas sur
le plateau le truc néclaire là je vous
ai préparé une liste mais on aura pas le
le temps dans dans on en parlait à rien
que les les derniers temps la Russie a
suspendu la ratification du traité de de
la de l'interdic des essais nucléaires
la Russie a remis en sur le sur le tapis
les essais nucléaires cheugou le
ministre de la Défense est allé à novim
là pour suivre les essais nucléaires ils
ont fait les essais sur un missile à à
propulsion nucléaire soi-disant
révolutionnaire qui qui peut durer
autant que qu'il veut il y a pire que ça
vous avez pas parler là de du conflit au
Proche Orient vous savez qu'il y a une
députée pakistanaise qui a dit il faut
lancer une bombe nucléire sur l'Israël
de Pakistan de
Pakistan Poutine a invité Kim Kim Jil en
Russie et il est venu laavrof est allé
là-bas chugou est allé là-bas donc la
Corée du Nord le pays qui est sous les
sanctions des Nations Unies du Conseil
de sécurité de l'assemblée générale la
Russie remet en en en question sa
coopération et parce que les Coréens
leur donnent des armes et du coup il y a
a il y a peut-être une coopération
nucléaire l'Iran qui a un programme
nucléaire les les Russes ont remis ont
réactivé leur leur relation avec l'Iran
et donc vous voyez les États-Unis ont
mis deux pores-avion face àisraël
actuellement il y a les Chinois qui
envoit aussi six bateaux dans la zone
Poutine a dit moi j'ai ordonné à mon
ministre de la Défense d'organiser les
euh les patrouilles de31 avec les
missiles kinjal et on sait pas si c'est
les missiles avec les têtes nucléaaires
ou pas sur la mer Noire donc vous voyez
sans vous faire peur là j'ai
énuméré faire peur j'ai énuméré j'ai
énuméré des choses ça veut dire j'ai
j'ai rien inventé là c'estàdire que vous
exposez quelque chose mais moi je vois
pas très bien le scénario en fait donc
vous nous parlez de menace nucléaire
concernant la Russie mais ce serait quoi
le déclencheur en fait oua qu'est-ce que
vous voyez comme scénario dans la dans
les toutes les guerr mondiales le
déclencheur en général c'est une chose
futile c'est vraiah oui con l'histoire
c'est une chose futile style
l'assassinat
dezog autrichien donc qu'est-ce qui
alors juste régisse la même question
est-ce qu'on risque une trème guerre
mondiale après ce qu'a dit Elon Musk
tout le monde bien sûr tout le monde
c'était dans les les têtes de tout le
monde mais c'est vrai que ça fait encore
plus flipper est-ce que on risque une tr
guerre mondiale là actuellement et
qu'est-ce qui ferait qu'on bascule dans
une trème guerre mondiale moi moi j'ai
tendance à être optimiste parce que je
pense que la situation est tellement
comment dire je je pense qu'en effet la
Russie est un la Russie est un élément
elle n'est pas l'élément déterminant
dans ce qui se passe notamment au Proche
Orient aujourd'hui ce qui se ferait ce
qui fait qu'on peut arriver vers une une
3ème guerre mondiale c'est une forme
d'alignement des alliances et de
multiplication des forces il y a 40 ans
je crois que c'était hier on a célébré
tristement l'attentat contre l'immeuble
rakar où 48 58 parachutistes français
avaient perdu leur vie c'était en 83 1
an après la création du hzbollah à
l'époque le hzbollah était un groupe
donc activiste comment un groupe de
résistance à Israël qui occupait le
Liban sud le Hezbollah est est devenu
aujourd'hui l'un des premiers groupes
armés internation nationaux c'est il a
un comment un pied en Irak il a une
milice qui s'appelle noujaba qui ce qui
est l'antenne du hzbollah local en Irak
il aide les outils au Yémen tout ça sous
la férule de l'Iran avec notamment la
force quotes donc les les les les les
Gardiens de la Révolution et tous ces
groupes par rapport c'est pour ça que je
dis c'était il y a 40 ans par rapport il
y a 40 ans ce sont considérablement
renforcé regardez les les les guerres
qu' a mené Israël contre le Hamas
c'était toujours il y avait en gros
Israël pertait
perdait comment un soldat pour 10
combattants pour il y avait 10
Palestiniens tué pour un Israélien là
aujourd'hui on a eu une attaque
fulgurante inattendue du Hamas avec sans
doute défaillance de sécurité de la part
d'Israël qui vont être examinés plus
tard mais on a un nombre de morts
israéliens considérable et on a
découvert que le Hamas c'était
considérablement renforcé donc
aujourd'hui on a des acteurs de part et
d'autre c'est plus simplement des
groupes armé qui mèneent des guerillas
ce sont de véritables groupes très
efficaces et qui peuvent éventuellement
infliger aux occidentaux ou ce qu'on
appellera une forme de coalition puisque
maintenant il y en a une sur place avec
les Américains des des dégâts
considérable les porte-avions vous savez
les porte-avions américains mais ils
sont vulnérables au Dron aujourd'hui
vous avez aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec la
guerre du
carabach l'armée de de de de l'Arménie
s'est fait décimer Ctait 72 c'est c'est
avec les drones il il n'avait pas prévu
la parade donc aujourd'hui vous pouvez
être le faible dit le faible et arriver
à attaquer le fort et aujourd'hui pour
pour être assez clair qu'est-ce qui peut
se passer parce que le danger vient d'où
vient de l'Iran est-ce que les
États-Unis peuvent s'emer on a vu on a
vu même il l'a dit he la Chine a
mis qui a intérêt à à des enfin la vraie
question là aujourd'hui c'est qui a
intérêt à ce que le conflit dégénère il
peut dégénérer en effet vous avez dit un
un évellement c'est ça le danger le
danger c'est que un un allié force les
autres à réagir et c'était ce qui
s'était passé he souvenez-vous la
Première Guerre mondiale un obscurch
archiduc qui meurt dans une ville sarevo
dont personne n'avait entendu parler le
nom et puis 4 semaines plus tard c'est
le plus grand conflit c'est le premier
conflit du 20e siècle et qui des
millions de personnes vont mourir donc
là on est dans une situation où je pense
très sincèrement qu'au niveau
international même s' a la guerre en
Ukraine il y a quand même une volonté de
maintenir le conflit dans la région
c'estd vous savez pour l'raine là on
parle aussi de ce qui se passe en israë
et en Palestine mais bien sûr mais
regardez pour l'Ukraine l'Ukraine on a
craint à un moment que le conflit allait
déborder il y avait eu ce fameux missile
qui avait atterri en Pologne vous aviez
la question de la Moldavie la
FR on a réussi globalement
internationalement à circonscrire le
conflit à l'Ukraine c'est un conflit
encore très dur où il y a des centaines
de morts tous les jours mais c'est un
conflit propre entre l'raine et la
Russie même si évidemment l'OTAN voilà
là je pense que la plupart des
dirigeants internationaux les Américains
et les russse quelque part cherche à ce
que le conflit n'aille pas au-delà de la
confrontation entre le Hamas et Israël
vous vous ne croyez pas ce qu'a dit Elon
Musk mais Elon Musk évidemment il a il a
repris la phrase d'ailleurs il a dit
sleep walking c'estàd il a dit on y va
comme des somnambules ce qu' avait dit
Henry Guo au début de la guerre en
Ukraine c'est-à-dire effectivement on
peut sans s'en apercevoir aller vers la
guerre maintenant je ne peux pas vous
affirmer et je j'ose espérer que une
solution et la paix va finir par par
germ je sais que ça paraît complètement
naïf de dire ça mais en tout cas que la
paix armée c'est c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement qu'on se regarde chacun
regarde l'autre et cetera le Hezbollah
il faut qu'il déclen si le hzbola
déclenche quelque chose sur Israël au
nord de la frontière là ça risque d'être
très compliqué je pense que j'ai
beaucoup plus de crainte sur ce qui peut
se passer à la frontière nord d'Israël
d'ailleurs netan où il était avec son
gilet par balle s'est fait filmer devant
les caméras hier parce que le hzbola
c'est le Hamas puissance 10 voilà euh
Pierre Martinet voulez je pense qu'on
prend pas en compte à suffisamment en
compte l'aspect idéologique de ce qui se
passe actuellement là-bas et au-delà
d'une seconde guerre mondiale ou une
3ème guerre mondiale pardon euh comme on
l' pu 4e oui une 4e ou une 5e enfin en
83 après après après dracar puisque j'y
étais il y a un vieux libanais qui avait
connu la Seconde Guerre mondiale il m'a
dit écoute bien la troisème guerre
mondiale sera a déjà commencé sur le sol
libanais elle sera religieuse on prend
pas assez en compte ce qui se passe
actuellement la dimension la dimension
idéologique ce matin le président
français a proposé une coalition
internationale pour éradiquer le Hamas
hein pas pour libérer les otages pour
éradiquer le Hamas donc ça voudrait dire
quoi ça voudrait dire qu' qu'il il y
aurait sur le sol de Gaza des militaires
français des forces spéciales françaises
américaines euh allemande britannique
c'est ce dont peur c'est dont ont peur
les Français he on l'a vu et ça pourit
déclencher des heures
intercommunautaires partout en Europe
vous avez vu ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
sur les en Europe ça c'est un réel
danger parce que les heures
intercommunautaires ça peut ça peut ça
peut être que d hein ça peut être deux
trois personnes avec deux kalashnikov
mais après ça peut dégénérer et puis
peut-être pas un conflit mondial mais
européen avec avec des des des poches de
de de guerrias civil en
Europe vu ce truc là parce que c'est
bien qu'on en parle ce soir tiens j'ai
vu un truc passer genre boycotte tes PMP
pourquoi par que je regarde pas moi les
réseaux et les les chiffres bidon oui
c'est ça d' oui ils prennent des
chiffres bidons et on sait très bien que
quand il y a du foot pardon de le dire
ce soir mais quand il y a du foot c'est
vrai qu'on
voilà donc il s'amuse à truquer les
chiffres et à direah regardez sur ce ce
score là par rapport à laille vra je
vais les arrêter tout de suite arrête ni
de truquer les chifffes rien du tout je
vais vous dire les gars on est jusqu'en
2026 jusqu'en 2026 donc ceux qui veulent
regarder avec grand plaisir et
franchement merci d'être aussi nombreux
à nous regarder et merci pour tous les
messages moi je regarde surtout les
messages positifs merci merci à vous
pour tous les messages positifs que nous
envoyz et ceux qui ne veulent pas
regarder on comprend tout à fait on leur
en veut pas et il y a aucun problème il
y a plein d'autres programmes très bien
et sachez-le TPMP là jusqu'en 2026 et
TPMP fait une rentrée voilà je vous dis
historique en audience donc voilà c'est
grâce à vous aussi c'est grâce à vous
qui nous suivez donc il y a aucune
question là-dessus juste la vraie
question c'est parce que j'ai vu moi ce
qui m'a plus gêné c'est Gil et moi et
Gil et moi je vous dis on a on n pas
d'accordant ça fait 10 ans qu'on est pas
d'accord je crois qu'on a jamais été
d'accord jamais voilà mais et moi on se
parle toujours contraire et on est pour
le dialue et
pour je vais vous dire un truc et je
pense que Gill si demain je l'appelle je
peux avoir une énorme galère je peux
vous dire à 4h du matin j'ai perdu mon
slip unuc comme ça et ben c'est lui qui
VI m'aider et il sait que s'il m'appelle
il sait que je toujours l'avez déjà
fait a eu des problèmes et cetera il
sait que je suis toujours là pour lui il
sait qu'il peut toujours compter sur moi
il sait que je peux compter sur lui gar
vous avez toujours été là voilà et on
sera toujours là pour toi mon Gilou même
si on n pas d'accord sur plein de choses
moi je vois plein de gens qui me disent
je vous jure et ça ça aussi ça m'énerve
arrêtez je vois plein de gens qui me
disent il faut virer Gill Verdez non
mais on est où là on est où là il faut
virer Gill Verdez sachez-le Gill ver ça
ressemble à
magaliez je vous dis c'est comme tu es
PMP jusqu'en 2026 Gill verd il sera
jamais viré voilà je vous le dis parce
que Gilles
verd voilà je te dis voilà il y a plein
de gens qui m'appellent mais je dis on n
pas d'accord sur plein de trucs il a
plein il faut virer Gill Verde a aussi
plein de messages qui disent bravo à ce
que dit
g parce que moi je parle de moi moi le
ressenti que j'ai parce qu'il y a plein
de gens qui dis faut que tu vir Gill non
mais on est fou quoi Gill Verdez il est
là et il sera là jusqu'en 2026 avec moi
s g disent il est humilié mais on SCPE
le chin on adore ça on revient tous les
jours Paron adore çaper le chignon pas
compris on comprend que c'est sympa le
qui est symptomatique sur le boycot TPMP
ici
on G lancéot mais
c'est
donre
jamais jamais à chaque fois qu'on donne
notre avis sur l'actualité et sur des
guerres c'est malheureux on donne notre
avis et là pour vous dire qu'on est sur
une poudrière assise sur une poudrière
c'est que là les mecs te lancent des
boycottes t PMP alors que c'est jamais
arrivé avant c'est quand même qu même
ass curiux et c'est tellement violent
sur les réseaux sociaux mais que même
quand on est pour la pai en fait et ben
ça ne va pas Mme mes de drapeau ça va
pas et je vous le dis vous ne vous
dérangez pas mais c'est message de haine
et cetera même les gars je ne regarde
rien je vous dis je suis au padol toute
la journée non mais je vais vous dire
les seuls trucs que je regarde c'est la
limite les résultat de paddle du
résultat du match à su enri et et
parfois il me disent ouais tu as vu sur
les réseaux qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur les
réseaux donc voilà donc je vous dis je
ne regarde rien et je m'en tape
totalement et Gill tu le sais mon chéri
voilà donc tu sais moi je ne regarde
rien et voilà non juste parfois il y a
des gens qui me disent faut virer Gill
verd voilà donc je vous confirme que
Gilles verd sera avec nous jusqu'en 2026
il sera plus je pense plus longtemps
dans l'émission avec Fatou
voilà jusque là c'était parfait c'est
jusque là c'était
parfait tu sais le problème que j'ai
c'est que je dis toujours ce que je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pense